oh how about well you know it was so
funny to me was David Beckham when
people were like man you can't allow a
guy with this much sauce to come to your
own wedding okay that guy is a [ __ ]
stud huh
debate he seems lock they say that guy's
a stud and then he's like I as it gaming
I'm do I he beat him but he's a stud
though dude
any time anyone wears a double-breasted
thing though they look [ __ ] horrible
that's so British to wear a
double-breasted thing and Tails I mean
so handsome God that guy
the to defy was that guy bro if I was
that guy I'd have all of the STDs I'd be
in jail I mean I'd be like oh I can't do
that look at me okay and I have that I
took it just stealing [ __ ] from like
families just I wanted the sandwich so I
went in the house and I got a sandwich
well you can't do that what are you
gonna not you want to gets to the gang
yeah all right I get you set up I'm just
gonna go take that sandwich to the cops
okay
dude I would be in jail I would be like
I wouldn't even understand if I was that
good-looking with that much money I
would be like on the stand be like I
would admit everything well I killed I
killed him why he was annoying the [ __ ]
out of me well you can't do that what do
you mean he was saying the same thing
over and over again and I kept giving
her the same answer
it was annoying [ __ ] so I [ __ ]
strangled him gonna be like well you're
gonna go to jail for a long time you
want to get to the game I mean we'd
would love to see a play but well just
said yeah okay well well I mean that's
what I would think would happen if I was
that guy the fact that David Beckham is
such a world-class guy and and like
that's amazing
him and his wife for the [ __ ] you know
does he cheat he's got to sorry and his
wife dude his wife's got to understand
if he cheats yeah
a bit you know there were 40 women they
were all tens they're all trying to suck
me Cal took it out and just like came
all over them but can't do that why not
you say me look at my bank account got a
lot of talent what's wrong
I mean I guess yeah I know okay I get I
guess um I mean you raise a fair point
but like come on I was a Spice Girl it
was a long time ago come on
well it's a Carmen over 40 women there
was in Las Vegas
a bit of fun you were all the way you
were over in the [ __ ] watching a
warrior wedding you were in brain I was
in Las Vegas I wanted to come that would
be me like this like they call statues
not as good as me
eat this what whoa [ __ ] why cuz I've
done everything else I want to say new
things put this in your eyes what put
this [ __ ] in your eyes no you cooked
this and I ate it I'm put in your eyes
that's how I would be if I was David
Beckham so the fact that he is such a
world clip you know what David Beckham's
the best human being in the world how
about that and his wife Bess Spice Girl
you know cuz David Beckham isn't doing
anything that's annoying as [ __ ] you
know these [ __ ] [ __ ] out
there doing [ __ ] cuz they think it's
right David Beckham is just this [ __ ]
dude you know what I'm saying it right
now David Beckham is my best friend I
never met him and he doesn't even know
who I am probably if you saw my comedy
be like yeah I don't really get it I
don't like him to be honest it's not
that good
it doesn't make me laugh he doesn't make
me laugh what he's saying and his faces
are stupid don't you think about that 40
girls don't you agree with me yeah yeah
yeah yeah can we suck your dick sure
let me Boston yeah we'll have a kid [ __ ]
it I want to see it all I want to have a
kid with you and then eat it
why I've done everything else you
[ __ ] idiot want you to labor for nine
months have a kid so I can eat it but
that's so inhumane I was saying may kick
a soccer ball but I don't want I'll get
to take it to the game could you write
down on a field level all right come
inside me that's how I would be if I was
David Beckham so props to David Beckham